>>> IT'S LOVE ISLAND, THE
UK REALITY STATION THAT AMERICA
IS OBSESSING OVER.
IT TURNS OUT THEY ALSO HAVE
100% PURE GRADE TRASH JUST LIKE
US.
LET'S MEET THE ISLANDERS.
>> I'M 22 IN LIVERPOOL.
YES.
BUT IF I WERE IN THE STATES, I'D
BE 41.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> I'M FROM ESSEX.
MY DAD IS A BOXER AND MY MUM IS
A PUB.
JUST GOT MY LIPS DONE.
I ASKED THE DOCTOR FOR AN
ALLERGIC REACTION.
>> I'M FROM MURDER SUICIDE,
ENGLAND.
I'VE GOT TWO MORE YEARS FOR MY
FACE TO CATCH UP TO MY LIVE.
>> I'M FROM THE PART OF IRELAND
WHERE THE SOIL IS BONES.
>> CALL ME FINLEY.
I'M FROM SCOTLAND BUT I'M ALSO
ITALIAN.
SO MY FATHER IS BASICALLY THE
SCARIEST GUY YOU'VE SEEN IN YOUR
LIFE.
>> I'M JUST LOOKING FOR A LADY,
LIKE A CHEAP ONE, FOR THE REST
OF MY LIFE.
>> THEY CALL ME MACKENZIE.
AND I'M LOOKING FOR THE PERFECT
GUY, BECAUSE THERE'S ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING WRONG WITH ME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WATCH THE HOTTEST PEOPLE FROM
THE WORST TOWNS IMMEDIATELY
COUPLE UP WITH SOMEONE BOSSED ON
NOTHING.
>> I WOULD LIKE TO COUPLE UP
WITH A GUY WHO'S EXACTLY MY TYPE
ON PAPER.
HE'S GOT TATTOOS.
HE'S GOT REALLY GREAT BANTER.
HE'S PROPER FIT.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, I WOULD GO
WITH ANYBODY.
EXCEPT YOU.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> HI.
>> OH.
YOU'VE GOT GREAT HAIR.
>> YOU'VE HEARD AN ENGLISH
ACCENT.
YOU'VE HEARD AN IRISH ACCENT.
NOW HEAR ALL THE LITTLE WEIRDIES
IN BETWEEN.
>> HE SCRATCHING ON HIS HEAD.
AND I'M LIKE --
[ SPEAKING FOREIGN LANGUAGE ]
>> WHAT?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, THEY DON'T EVEN
UNDERSTAND EACH OTHER.
TUNE IN AS THEY FACE CHALLENGES
LIKE GETTING UP FROM A BEANBAG.
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU WILL WATCH 50 HOURS OF THIS.
YOU THINK YOU WON'T, BUT YOU
WILL.
>> I'M REALLY LOOKING FORWARD TO
SLEEPING WITH ALL MY NEW
FRIENDS.
AND I MIGHT EVEN GET IN THE
WEE
PUDDLE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YOU'LL INVEST IN VULNERABLE
MOMENTS LIKE WHEN THE GIRLS TAKE
THEIR MAKEUP OFF.
>> YOU KNOW, I PUT SO MUCH
BRONZER ON I THINK I MIGHT BE
DOING BROWNFACE.
IS THIS A HATE CRIME?
>> THAT'S NOT BAD, IS IT?
I LOOK REALLY DIFFERENT WITHOUT
ME MAKEUP ON 'CAUSE OF THE
CONTOUR.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> SHE'S A REALLY NICE GIRL, BUT
I THINK HER FACE MIGHT BE A
SONG.
>> WHAT?
>> AT ANY POINT SOMEONE MAY BE
FORCED TO LEAVE THE VILLA AND
TURN IN THEIR GIANT MICROPHONE.
>> THIS BIRD AND I GOT GREAT
CRACK.
SHE'S GOT A GREAT PERSONALITY.
BUT MOSTLY OF ALL THE GIRLS
HERE, SHE WAS THE MOST BIKINI.
FOR A PERSON I WOULD LIKE TO
COUPLE UP --
GRACE.
>> I KNEW IT, I KNEW IT.
I KNEW IT.
>> HOPPING SPIT IN MY FACE.
I'M ABSOLUTELY GUTTED.
[ PHONE CHIMES ]
ARE YOU JOKING?
1.10 MILLION INSTAGRAM
FOLLOWERS.
I DON'T HAVE TO BE A STUPID
PEDIATRIC NURSE ANYMORE, DO I?
CHA-CHING.
>> LOVE ISLAND NOW AVAILABLE